david calls me he goes hey yeah i got to
go downtown i got to do this jewish
this jewish group they want me to do
stand-up but i got to have you because
you can get them going i i can't get
these people going right away so i need
somebody with energy
i go i'll come down what the [ __ ] no
i'll give you if i give you 400 bucks so
i don't know what the [ __ ] they're
paying them
i go you don't give me money i'll just
come down with you because no no i'm
gonna all right so i get there
and i walk in and it's a bar it's a
[ __ ] bar
and they're they're it's noisy as [ __ ]
because it's after work
and it's happy hour and it's a happy
hour bar corporate bar
okay well where are we going to stand up
upstairs go upstairs
we go upstairs i look around i go well i
can hear them
because i'm upstairs but there's if it's
a balcony so i look over
i can hear that oh no that's cool no no
don't worry because we're gonna get
people to come up
and i go where's the sound system he
he pulls out you know one of those boxes
those amplifiers that you would use for
your electric guitar if you like you're
on the subway
so i go that's what you have and he goes
yeah and the guy in the [ __ ] head goes
and plugs in a mic so i go where's the
stage
and the guy goes well we don't have a
but maybe you could use this couch this
is a true story standing on the couch
that was a true story so i go
the couch now ready it was a children's
couch it was a
it was a couch that was this big mini
futon it was that well it's like you
know what it was
the kind of couch you put your dog on
yeah you buy it in a dog in a pet store
it's a dog couch so i go
so i i get up on the couch now here's
what you don't realize brennan the
ceiling was
low so it was touching my head
people come up and i decide to open up
with
and they're all sitting on the floor
because there's nowhere to sit you
understand grown members
oh yeah grown men and then and it was a
jewish for a jewish
charity of some kind and that's how we
did stand up
how'd the show go oh it went so great
they're like oh it went
great oh dude it went great yeah
i had to open so that was fantastic
sometimes i don't mind those corporate
gigs why because everybody was talking
downstairs and
it was so it was so common i'm sure
you've had some rough ones
yeah but if they throw enough money at
you it's like who gives a [ __ ] one time
my brother
my brother somehow orchestrated this
crazy corporate gig for me he was
golfing with some guy who like owns a
bunch of toyota dealerships in seattle
and he's like all right so i just it's
funny the way he was bullshitting
through
you know they're playing golf and he's
like yeah my brother you know he's a
stand-up
he's at the comedy store and he acts you
can look at his imdb
and you know normally his rate is just
bullshitting like
and he gets me like 4 500 for it or
something for 30 minutes of stand up
yeah i'm coming for some toyota
christmas party thing
i'm like of course so i go there and
it's just not set up for comedy it's
like lunch room tables you know the
circles
just super bright there's buffets people
are mingling
and stuff and they don't music is okay
because you could passively enjoy that
i have to go up after this band and they
just want to talk to each other
so i'm up there just like talking to a
wall of sound
and they're all talking they're not
paying attention and i'm just like on
autopilot
there's no way to see the 30. yeah
because in my mind i'm like all i got to
do is not
snap and collect my check
yeah all i have to do is put on a smile
go through the motions
and if anyone wants to tune in they'll
get a show this is this guy's blunder
not mine you know his people didn't want
comedy
so i just kind of like pace back and
forth do my thing for 30 minutes
eat [ __ ] and then the guy has to
grudgingly write a check to me he's like
i'm like how much was that yeah i'm like
nice doing business
i would do that over and over again i
did i did a wedding
in san diego same situation same
situation
then i did the river keepers you know
what that is
bring up river keepers benefit you
remember when i did fishing giggles and
you called you filmed it you go well
this one
that's nothing about five years ago yeah
that that was terrible because
brennan just wrote jesus but i did
river keepers which is an amazing thing
for um bobby kennedy
i had done this this thing in at the
biggest house government official
bobby kennedy yeah so so i did he come
out to me i i did that
everybody was there everybody huge was
there in la i killed it that guy
and i i did really well and he came up
and he said can you do that
can you do that again and i said yeah
i'm a comic i crushed it
like with all these famous people
lincoln park was there and i [ __ ]
destroyed
it was great they it was like this it
was in this in this tent
but it was in la at this biggest house
so whatever i hit one i did i did well
yeah
and every celebrity is there and
everything else so he comes up and
because can you do that for me
at the river's keepers i get there in
new york it's
1100 people in an airplane hangar it's
1100 people in an airplane hangar
and they've they put me up when people
were eating
and talking and i had to do stand up a
lot of whites
oh no no it was blue-collar union guys
oh yeah
i ate i ate such a dick
and this is when i was like doing great
i ate such a dick i
when i think about it i get embarrassed
when i think about it it's still in her
wheelchair everybody came dude everybody
came
when i no he wasn't there he was dead
but they had a picture of him when i
came well no dude oh chelsea clinton was
there everybody was there
what are you talking about everybody's
there i think hillary had when hillary
was there
what did you do are you still mingling
and [ __ ] or do you get out i
ran away i actually went to my room and
i wouldn't leave and bobby called me and
said you impressed a lot of people today
he was such a nice guy
but he felt so bad yeah bobby right
there he's great
i think that's his name bobby kennedy
but dude i ate
all the relationships i mean that's such
a power move too you're like his name
bobby kennedy yeah
in front of 1100 people i ran away
arnold was there
everybody dude everybody i ate all the
dicks in front of everybody
everybody and one guy came up to me and
thought i was funny one guy
i wouldn't leave me alone what was his
name doesn't matter
that's bobby kennedy i cringe when i
think about it i
i've there's nothing worse than being a
comic and doing and eating all the dicks
in front of 1100 people
in new york city and while a
professional hockey player who's a
legend can't remember his name
introduces you and then goes like this
you come off and he goes tough gig a
tough one
well you saw tim tebow thing too where i
ate all
i don't do any of these things anymore i
don't know well jay's wife had
every year they they uh have they would
i think they fly to santa barbara or
marina del rey i forget where
but they always have a comic open up and
they they've hired the biggest comics
yeah
and they had a comic come in there oh i
think it was aziz
and sorry and he gets there and you know
he
you know he does his thing they give him
the stage he just looked around
and i guess he just started roasting
every just started lighting them up
and destroyed but before that everyone
ate dicks yeah
dicks you got to do that but with uh
brian with tim tebow so
tim tim is a good buddy and he has this
tim
tim tebow uh charity event where there's
golf and there's a whole foundation
and i've been to it like five years in a
row and they always have these awful
comedians open up and they eat
[ __ ] i go dude you need a real comedian
i'll get you a real comedian cause yeah
i go yeah my boy brian would do it
he's like yeah but isn't brian like a
little dirty no brian has clean material
so i call brian mckay i can get you we
will fly out first class all this stuff
but it has to be like clean material
dude you can't have any
no dick grabbing none of that and
brian's like yeah dude i'm professional
i got this
this dude goes up there first i see kids
sick kids hold on sick kids no they're
on the last leg it's like
literally make a wish okay they're
carting them in the back like right here
everybody here's brian kell from matt
baby
rolls up the kids are on their
ventilators the whole work so i'm like
oh dude don't [ __ ] this up brian
and i'm sitting there and uh tim's
brother robbie i'm really good friends
was like hey
he's gonna be good right yeah i've gone
over it man he's good man and they go
okay here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna say prayer and then we'll
bring up brian i go
i would uh i would i would rather you
say prayer like do something and then
bring up brian he's like
dude that's all we have time for so they
say prayer everyone you know everyone's
super religious there
he goes down they go all right everybody
now put your hands together for brian
count
brian gets up then it's a super
religious group and brian goes
well one thing you know jesus is a lot
better at a number of things than me one
thing's not funnier than me
the the audience crickets and i was like
up here like they took it literally
oh
meyer loved it he was like can you come
talk to my boys i'm like i'm not doing
any of this [ __ ]
i'm never doing stand up again like this
this is that was it was my fault these
are great opportunities to mingle with
these type of people but
very rarely does it go well it's always
the best when they come to the store
well also when they put governor
governor on you and you see sick kids in
the audience yeah
now i got to tailor my [ __ ] right away i
got i i should have put you in that
situation no
you didn't know you didn't know i was
like all the comments that we had they
went through this mic
you would i would have been fine if i
had gone for it but that was
well if they let you do your thing yeah
but i could it's very it's very hard to
like
edit yourself in real time yeah this gig
yeah but what else is crazy like people
don't realize like why do people do
these corporate gigs
when you find out how how much some of
these comics you're getting for
corporate gig
how to blow your mind right now blow
your mind yeah
it's not like you seek them out but if
it lands in your lap you're like yeah i
guess some do though i know some really
big comics dude that's
you know they do a lot of corporate gigs
and they make [ __ ] you know you're
talking six figure pages
for 30 minutes yeah but again you're
you're tailing they're super clean
comics they're tailing towards the crowd
yeah it's just purely a money play and
if that's your thing that's great but
yeah i i i feel like i'm being rented
and i feel like i'm compromised doing it
for the wrong reason
if you're doing [ __ ] for the wrong
reason you're always gonna i feel like
i'm lying when i'm up there
think about michelle wolf think about
the balls no pun intend think about the
balls
oh my god when they go hey i want you to
speak at the at the white house
and i guess i heard her talk about this
i forget where but she was like
i'm going to do this and i know i'm all
the dicks in the room
but the comics out there and everybody
see this you're gonna love it
so she goes as i'm doing in my head i'm
thinking about other people not the
people in the room
yeah there's two audiences sometimes
when you do things like that there's the
audience in the room and the audience
who are consuming it on a screen
so it's like she was she was calling for
the internet that's what she was pissed
yeah that's what she said she was
picturing the internet and like
other comics watching it not she's in
the room have you watched it
i'm in the room people are just like
yeah she was great down oh she
was supposed to write on uh hassan was
doing it again
this year and i was going to be on the
writing team for it but then on the
house for the yeah for the
correspondence thing but then corona hit
and it put the brakes on it
so i mean that would have been a fun
thing to do like i've always wanted to
do that
yeah michelle's a beast i i she's i like
her so much because i don't even know
her and i saw her in new york at the
comedy cellar and
she saw me she goes hi and she gave me a
hug and i was like what a [ __ ] sweet
person yeah
i saw in the back room at the at the the
store and got real nervous
just kind of like disappeared into the
night she's such a sweet i don't know
why
she's a real comic she's a real comic
yeah
it took some balls because you know
you're going down in flames in the room
but you're gonna be a hero to half yeah
you ever see
uh stephen colbert's that's one of my
favorites
like stephen colbert's white house
correspondents dinner speech
is like one of my favorites that kind of
started the whole year just like
during obama's right he's not he was
bushes he's was it bush
he's [ __ ] amazing you know that
colbert
lost his two brothers and his father in
a plane crash yeah at the same time
his family right and then some of his
family died too i thought well two
brothers and his father
and then maybe someone else i don't know
that's crazy but he's
so funny colbert was
so good he's so good he's so good you
don't get better than that
you know mitch uh and he did strangers
with candy a lot
colbert what a beast i'll tell you this
right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing